produce industry does not have the right
to dump nutritious product that can go
to families who are in need
borderlands food bank rescues between 30
to 40 million pounds of produce annually
and we've been doing it for 21 years
my name is rolanda soto and i am the ceo
president of borderlands food bank
we are an organization that rescues
fresh produce we get it to families all
over the state of arizona and 19 other
states within the nation
we saw there was a tremendous amount of
fresh produce coming across at our port
of entry here from mexico and a lot of
it could not be sold
it could be because it had some scarring
it could be because it had some rain
stain
and so they were actually dumping it in
the landfill
we saw that the product was extremely
good
for human consumption so we began
educating the produce industry
we've gone to each individual
distributor we've offered them our
services and said do not dump
allow us to rescue it and get it to
families so that they can eat
nutritiously
the driver comes back to the warehouse
he's got a trailer load of product and
he begins to get unloaded
we take up the produce to the sites and
we set it up like a farmers market all
done by volunteers from the host site
for a 10 contribution the supporter can
select 60 pounds of produce pretty good
17 cents a pound
it's important to us to get it to as
many families as possible before it
perishes because i think that people
have the right to eat nutritiously it's
the most basic of needs thank you have a
great day
we have
the responsibility
to stop waste
and we have the responsibility to help
the people in our own backyard
you